[موسيقى]
ألق نظرة على بعض الصور الرائعة
للطبيعة الأم بكل
روعتها المذهلة ، حيث تعرض مسابقة التصوير الفوتوغرافي للعالم الطبيعي للصورة الكبيرة
سنويًا
أعمالًا مذهلة من مصوري الحياة البرية
والبيئة من
جميع أنحاء العالم عبر أكثر من 7000 صورة من
65 دولة تم تقليصها إلى
حفنة من المتأهلين للتصفيات النهائية عبر
فئات متعددة بما في ذلك المناظر الطبيعية ،
الحياة المائية المجنحة وأكثر من ذلك ،
تم نشر الصور في الأصل في السيرة الذاتية
وهي مجلة مستقلة حول الطبيعة
والمحافظة عليها مدعومة من أكاديمية كاليفورنيا
للعلوم والشريك الإعلامي
للمسابقة ، استحوذ المتنافسون المهتمون على بعض الأفكار-
لحظات محيرة من عوالم خفية من العجائب إلى
مواجهات مفترسة مخيفة ولكن في
النهاية كان هذا الإدخال من
مصور أمريكي الذي التقط
رقصة التزاوج الفوضوية لنحل الصبار الذي يتنافس
على عاطفة أنثى التي حصلت
على
الجائزة الكبرى في لحظة صاخبة بالفعل